in some sense
the few people have turned down the
prize made a much more powerful
statement
i i don't know if you're familiar with
in the in the space of mathematics with
the fields metal
and google perlman yes to turn down the
prize
it's uh so he i've committed one of the
reasons i started this podcast is i
i'm going to definitely talk to putin
i'm go definitely talking to perlman and
people keep telling me it's impossible
i love hearing that because i'll talk to
both anyway but
do you have us do you have a sense
of um why he turned down the prize
and is that a powerful statement to you
well what i read is that um
you're talking about the mathematician
the mathematician what i read is that
he was disappointed by the response of
the community the mainstream community
the mathematicians to his earlier work
where they dismissed it
they didn't attend to the details and
and
didn't treat him with proper respect
because he was not considered
one of them yes and i think that speaks
uh volumes
about the current scientific culture
which is uh
based on group think and on
social interaction rather than on the
merit of the argument
and on the evidence in the context of
physics so in mathematics there is no
empirical basis you're exploring ideas
that are logically consistent uh but
nevertheless there is this
group thing and i think he was so
frustrated
with his past experience that he didn't
even bother to publish his papers he
just posted them on the archive and um
in a way
saying you know i know what what the
answer is
go look at it and then again
in the long arc of history uh his work
on archive will be remembered and all
the prizes
most of the prizes will be forgotten
that's what people don't
kind of think about
you